start um
three me for the for the commission
members uh I got a call from Lou
delandro last night he's uh got a
doctor's appointment he'll probably be
about an hour late so count the second
half of the
meeting uh got a call from
representative brudy who also just got a
picked up a doctor's appointment this
morning but he said it' only be about 15
minutes late we'll see and then I I just
talked to uh representative Jian who was
on the r coming in from California from
LA and he is on the way here he he
dropped his wife off in Sal them and
he's he's going to make it so
um but with with that I think we should
we should start anyway so I'm going to
call the meeting to
order uh let's start with the pledge uh
Charlie you want to want to help us out
here FL of the United States of America
and the Republic which it stand One
Nation
indivisible
andice so we've invited a variety of
guests on different issues uh but I
don't seem to see anybody from the
Charities anybody hear from the
Charities uh there my glasses
here you sen for nonprofits but our our
three guests uh don Mory not here uh
Mike
borano not here and Larry caman not here
right well they may come in a little
late so we can always jiggle the the
agenda around if they come we can we'll
try to fit them in that was going to be
a panel discussion uh by these
Charities so first thing is to approve
the minutes from the last meeting do I
have a
motion second okay Ling second Charlie
um okay
any
discussion no okay all in favor
approving the minutes say I I well
opposed n okay minutes are
approved okay as you know we are in the
process
of um RP process and I first agenda
items is to Charlie to give us a quick
update on where we're at um good morning
chairman morning members um RFP is
scheduled to have submissions from
potential um vendors this week uh there
was a question answer period uh the
questions came in a couple of vendors uh
I generated answers I shared them with
the chair there was nothing really
substantive more procedural in terms of
the questions that were submitted so um
and if you're interested they're
available on the website I know where I
can pass out copies if needed um and
like I said the submissions from
potential vendors is to this week so um
that's where we are yeah I I think we
agreed
that to review the proposals uh that' be
you Senator Langan and uh and me yeah we
do that okay and hopefully we can do
that between now and in the next meeting
yeah certainly one of the things that
would made me feel hardened is that one
of the questions came in from somebody
that I had sent the RFP to so that the
community has actually read that the
okay one of the potential vendors wasn't
one of the ones that I had sent it to as
a company does this so there is interest
okay all right so that's that update
um we've been talking about uh problem
gambling for a while uh so uh we decided
to invite more
McAn uh who heads up more wanted you
explain your position and I know it's
not problem gambling I I got already
getting wrong responsible gambling thank
you
you gotta push the
button perfect oh just for everybody's
uh
edification uh this is is being
broadcast this and it'll be on YouTube
so anybody who comes late I'm going to
direct them to your comments on the
commission um on a later date so thank
you sure morea aan and I sit on the
council um for responsible gambling here
in the state of New New Hampshire and it
was really with director McIntyre when
he came on more than a dozen years ago
that he brought this forward to us and
for a 10-year period we actually
supported problem gambling responsible
gambling here in the state for
approximately
$25,000 a year as well as in kind
donation so we did that for 10 years and
then uh there was actually funding
funding to help with this here in the
state um it was
$250,000 a year of which it was cut to
$100,000 a year so for FY 21 through
23 the amount of money that we had was
$1,000 a year and we went out to an RFP
and the RFP was actually awarded to a
local group here it was the original
group that we had worked with the
previous 10 years it was the Council on
problem gambling so that Council over
that three-year period they manned the
24hour 7 days a week 365 days a year
hotline um they also did
presentations they attended um GA
meetings
and they also this past year started
with some um Mental Health Providers and
actually doing training with them for
this current fiscal year the funding was
restored to the full
$250,000 a
year the original Council that had been
working with us
declined to work further in this fiscal
year
and at this time we
are working on getting the 24hour
hotline it is still being answered but
it's being answered by a private
individual but we are working on getting
that hotline up and going and I have
spoken with three entities the mass
Council as well as Maine
211 211 New
Hampshire
and both of the entities in both Maine
and New Hampshire have been wonderful
and gracious to speak
with their concern is taking the calls
of which they can yes but it's going
Beyond and finding Mental Health
Providers to help with people that may
have a problem with this addiction so
they have assured me that they can yes
take the calls and yes we did speak with
Maine because Maine said they would be
more than happy to help us out but also
211 New Hampshire said that they would
be able to
also it was just that at that point they
had little resources to actually turn
the people over to for assistance so
right now we are working through um
putting out an RFP in in order to have
that hotline answered and then hopefully
further working with whoever it is
awarded to in order to find the
resources to actually get these people
help so in a nutshell that's the past 13
years okay well thank you for that so
I'll have a first question here um so
when we did historic racing machines um
there was a provision that all the
breakage you got
the was to go to this
fund um we learned the other day the
last meeting that two of the three
vendors that provide the historic racing
machines are complying with that and
that's another agender item we're going
to talk about but so that money is going
into the same fund
correct actually I answer that okay uh
it was it's in law but not in
budget so it has to be in both
it was unbudgeted as part of
the the state budget so the the council
gets
$2,000 the funding source is breakage if
it exceeds that um then the money you
know understand what I'm saying say so
so where's the breakage going so the
breakage is going to responsible
gambling it's just in in past years the
number for breakage has exceeded the
amount
budgeted this year it won't because it
was as as Morris suggested it's been
raised to $50,000 I got it okay
so so do do one more time I don't have
certainly
so obviously there was a dedicated fund
to fund responsible gambling right that
Source was breakage in Prior years
breakage amount exceeded the amount
budgeted okay and so the exess returns
to the education trust fund okay that's
what okay I got it I don't keep it all
right let me turn to the education one
all right so so what we're saying is
that uh if we budgeted 250 you're back
to 250
again
right so if we're back up to 250 can we
over ever exceed to 250 if if the
breakage is exceeds to 250 it doesn't
sound like it or if we have to do
something next buer cycle that would
yeah we have to do the next budget cycle
okay to
to well then but then the finance have
to figure out how much is coming from um
how much we anticipate it's going to
come from the breakage I mean we'll have
a better handle on it because we
obviously now we have experience right
moreover there's not a breakage fund
coming from the not just one of the
manufacturers but the largest by far is
not funding
breakage okay and so in break we would
may want to legislative fix to that
that's an ex agender item so so okay so
uh questions
I'm looking at you because I know
you yeah just backing up a little bit
um you're with
the Lottery Commission I am I am
actually the director of marketing and
advertising with the lottery yeah which
is a very nice place to
be because it goes hand inand with
understanding responsible gambling so
whenever I'm working on a
project to promote Lottery to promote
our games that responsible gambling is
always in the back of my head
yeah and then um you're part
of the you're appointed
to the council is that list nominated by
the governor and approved by the
executive Council and the name of the
organ
of
this The Entity we're now talking about
is what the New Hampshire Council for
responsible gambling have a council for
respons and who who's on who are the
others besides
you uh we have four other members uh two
of them are um doctors that work with
addiction I just double checking yeah I
I was shown uh uh would you like me to
continue or do you do have L of five
well I I see um and how often do you
meet we try to meet
quarterly um unfortunately um throughout
the covid years it was a little bit more
difficult and uh this particular year we
have not been able to meet um on that
quarterly basis but we are in touch with
each other okay all right right
um and then what you meet and talk about
is the uh agenda for problem gam
gambling and the money that uh has been
the finances yes as well as the RFP as
well as um the research that goes in um
prior to the RFP being U
drafted
okay is there a sense of things that
need to be done but we can't do them uh
kind you know your perspective sitting
on this Council and you asked to deal
with responsible gambling or problem
gambling which everyone one wants to
call it and uh but oh gosh we can't do
this because you know this that and the
other thing yes can you can you talk
about that sure so over the past 13
years we have made great strides um
great strides in getting information out
regarding problem gambling there are
posters as as well as brochures that are
in each charitable gaming location um
there is our website of course that also
provides assistance and we work uh with
the National Council um and as well as
uh locally here so again right now we
certainly need a hotline that's up and
running as well as the resources to send
those people to once they make
call there are other projects that we
would very much like to become a part of
and that would be the ability
to exclude yourself from going into a
charitable casino and do it online
currently in order to do that they must
go into the casino in order to complete
the paperwork to exclude themselves but
the ability to do it online and to share
it throughout the 10 to 15 casinos here
is a project that we will be working
on okay well why don't I I'll leave at
that for okay I have another question so
do you keep statistics on how many
people are actually trying to access a
hotline or do we have those kind of
numbers the local um gentleman Ed Talbot
that answers he gets about five to six
calls a month
and then I spoke with the national uh
Council and they tell me they get about
50 calls a
month so interesting because you know we
uh actually representative Ames got this
letter from Ed
talet and then I tried to track Ed talet
down at the number and it was part of
another uh charitable group that they
said he's not part of the charitable
group anymore so I had trouble finding
him so maybe after the meeting or you
can email I will get in touch with you
yes we'd like to talk to it eventually
as well so he's more the guy on the
ground
actually his people dealing with he
answers the phone the problem gambling
the number that's locally here in New
Hampshire yes okay all right so we may
have him at another meeting thank you
for that so when when the
250,000 that com out of a general fund
I'll ask you to try no it's Ed it's
Lottery funds it comes out of Lottery
funds correct okay all right just want
to understand that all right any other
questions it's was considered an expense
of the lottery right thank you for
taking my question so my question is
going to come around the idea of
self-exclusion and how that's managed
here in the state of New Hampshire can
you speak a little further on that I
understand there's a
little a call it a fluffle going on
between how one someone who might be
self- excluded from one entity can walk
into another entity and there's no
tracking of that person's excluded
excluded thems and would be able to walk
in can you talk about ideas around that
right so the thought is well
currently in order to self-exclude from
all of them the individual would have to
visit each Casino complete each
paperwork in order to be
self-excluded what we would like to do
and we've spoken with other groups that
do it for example in Massachusetts game
sense in
Massachusetts they have a self-exclusion
online where you can exclude yourself
from all of the entities at the same
time and that information is shared with
each entity be at each
Casino oh so that's a
contracted process not the state holding
the data but somebody else holding the
data anding
correct thank
you yes I apologize being for being late
uh but with with the with reference to
the
exclusion we have we have a number of
facilities operating at the present time
we think we have 10 maybe we have 15
we're talking about
20 is it it from your from your
standpoint is it the responsibility of
the entities to share the exclusionary
information if someone has has done that
or does each one have to have to
identify and keep the data them
themselves currently they all keep the
data themselves and they do not share it
with the other
entities forther question Mr CH oh yeah
follow okay does doesn't that appear to
be problematic to to you that if you
know about it and they're at another
venue and you haven't shared that
information with them uh it's you're
exacerbating the problem certainly it's
difficult to have to send somebody into
the place that they want to exclude
themselves from that is
recognized and it's recognized further
that the best case scenario would be to
have the ability to go online exclude
yourself from going and to have that
information shared with all of our
charitable casinos here in New Hampshire
yes
is is is there any attempt to put that
in
place certainly we've done research
we've spoken with Massachusetts in game
sense as well as in the state of Maine
Maine 211 has an individual that
actually helps people to exclude them
themselves from I do believe they have
two in the state of Maine two casinos
right now right right Bor
and the other one Ox o Bango bango's got
the slot house right and and just one
one further point the 800 number that
appears we we we've got some advertising
that appears on on television on that
800 number that appears right at the end
of it who answer was that 800 number
that's actually the um the folks at
DraftKings I think you're referring to a
sports betting right so that that
telephone number goes to them okay and I
guess the last question it it it turs
then of of of the persons identify
themselves what what happens after that
is there is do they refer them to uh to
some kind of uh treatment situation or
in speaking with DraftKings um they help
to identify specifically what the
individual wants if they want their
account closed if they're looking for
assistance yes they work through that
with them and identify the reason why
they are calling okay thank you yeah
Charlie's ell no it's part of the I
could um Senator as part of the law
allowing sports betting is there was a
requirement to have a responsible
gambling plan place um and uh drafting
specifically has a self-exclusion
function on the phone or in your laptop
and there are hundreds of hundreds of
people who have excluded themselves from
DraftKings intentionally okay great
that's good thank you thank you very
much thank you so I'm G to switch and
talk about a little pragmatic and I'm
gonna ask you as a as an
operator what are the what are the
barriers to allow that data sharing to
allow for the self- exclusion to be able
to go between gaming
organizations uh right now I think most
of the rooms would love if it was all in
syn and we could all Let each other know
it's a little problematic cuz it's
private information so they to come in
and sign off on it so that we're
protecting ourselves against them saying
we're biased or it's because I won or
who knows so you know we'd love if it
was an online form I know there's
hurdles and in New Hampshire like you
can't save ID information so that's a
hurdle so you really have to try to
catch them right the door which is part
of why we C everybody and then our
security team tries to keep each other
updated on who to look for who
self-excluded and so forth so there's
definitely some hurdles that would have
to be worked out so to make it
accessible to all
the balance between Charlie and J
understand again I'm trying to
understand is there a legal U barrier
here somewhere in our law that says that
you're not allowed to scan that
information if we were to enter into a
contract with someone like gam sense to
be able to share this data are there
legal barriers in the way right now that
would prohibit the use of that kind of
contracting service um I mean certainly
I would think at least Hippa would be I
would look for the Attorney General's
opinion in terms of law but since it is
classified of the DSM as a as an
addiction it would be health related and
sort of it would require I think a
change in the law like ideally you would
have one central location on our website
or their website where you would go and
say I wish to be excluded from these
things and because we have two platforms
that are digital right we have an ey
Lottery platform and we have a sports
Bank platform both of which have had
self exclusion functions and um
limitations like you can limit yourself
$10 a month or whatever uh and so you
could have a central portal where you
could go and that would be shared with
the operators as part of their
responsible gambling responsibility is
which we also audit so
um so hip I don't think would apply
because it applies with employers and
insurance carriers and providers and not
necessarily in this situation but um
again I'm just concerned is there
anything G mentioned the there's some
sort of prohibition about scanning and
storing data in in law maybe is it is
that in the law do we know or is that um
are we familiar with any of that not I'm
not all right so it doesn't sound like
there's a legal barrier to this
operation other than maybe a pragmatic
barrier a maybe AG can help us out yeah
let me let me just ask one one question
of G on a pragmatic person again when
somebody walks into a gaming operator
you take their ID you scan it through
one of those scanning devices they use
like a TSA and it identifies the person
says they're legal it's a valid ID and
they're over
21 or 18 what they yes that's correct um
with that we can't save their ID so it
won't like pop up and say they're
self-excluded because you can't keep
their information is my
understanding
stored
okay
John Let's sit up
here and U his card is underneath yours
Senator so you been your yeah so uh from
the AG's P office
perspective can something that's
something we have to take back as a
research project to see whether or not
there's any sort of legal impediment uh
to scanning and storing that information
but if I could make a f if I could make
a follow-up question I'm curious as to
how the state deals with if at all a
band players list so if facilities ban
players from their facility is that
information shared and is that stored
someplace several states do do that
Nevada being one of them I I I don't
know the answer so that's not a a
problem responsible ging problem that's
a I don't know the answer to that i'
have to check right so Qui follow follow
so again so the interesting part is that
again someone would have to add
voluntarily add themselves to the list
and the only thing we would be doing is
validating against that list if I'm not
mistaken is that is that right so to to
G's point about storing and scanning
right we're not storing any customer
data or private data at that point we're
taking the ID putting it through comp
parent against a known list of people
who either this you brought up a new
topic of ban but people who have
self-excluded and then saying you've
already self-excluded at this venue and
you're so therefore you're not allowed
here at the second venue as well so I'm
not sure that we hit the scan and scan
and store problem that she's talking
about um because the person's
voluntarily putting their name into the
database but the band is an interesting
new wrinkle I hadn't thought about okay
well it okay represent
Ames just a suggestion it seems to me
that we would be uh helped if we could
get the Maine and uh
Massachusetts uh counterpart
organizations some representative in
here to speak with us about this yeah
can you help us with
that so I I think again again what this
commission is doing is trying to
identify issues that need addressing and
it sounds like that this has some
addressing that needs to be done uh so
that we can recommend changes for the
future uh that may require legislation
uh but be helpful if the AG could weigh
in a little bit if on this issue down
the road um so uh thank you very much
because it's it's opened our eyes a
little bit it seems like we yeah we got
a program but it it's really got a ways
to go um and especially with charel
gaming growing the way it is now in the
state um I think it's a relevant
discussion to have so any other
questions very good point Mr chairman
the fact of the matter is the expansion
with the number the number of entities
offering charitable
gaming creates a pro creates a problem
with surveillance and and with the
ability to to
uh oversee this activity I mean the L
the lottery the
commission it's it's your
responsibility but when you go from 10
to 15 to 20 right you're you're talking
about 20 facilities that are that are
working almost 24/7 MH at at this point
at this point in time and remember when
we initiated the lottery it was a sweet
Stakes race that happened once a year
you bought you bought a ticket for $3
you signed your name you gave it back
and they had a race at at Rocky Park uh
I I think as pointed out by
representative Ames Massachusetts and
and and and Main they're in the business
now they they have a limited number of
facilities uh but they're in the
business and many of these queries that
we've posted at at this point in time
had to be addressed by
them had to be but it sounds like they
have a tech technological solution yeah
right that they if if one one presents
everybody knows I mean it's not that
it's we actually going to have more
facilities than they do we they have two
or three in these states we have 15
right well probably 14 now but let's
call it 15 and maybe up to 19 uh per our
last
discussions uh I mean it does beg for a
technological solution I think we have
to get over some of these legal barriers
of of of whether the data is secure or
not secure does it have to be or not uh
but I think this something that the
committee can take up as as the months
go
on so again I just ask as a homework
assignment if the AG and then and the
Hampshire Council for responsible gaming
can take a look at what legislative
changes do we need enabling statute to
enable this systemwide solution or is
the law okay we just need to implement
right there's no change needed we just
got to do it so I'd be interested in
knowing whether what what that barrier
is and and so we can act on it
accordingly we'll take that back to the
shop and and take a look
right um Mark you know um I text him
John our chief compliance officer is
watching this you know um he has a
research project on it so he's already
done a bunch of work on that yeah yeah
so if you want to link with John I I'll
touch Bas I don't want to get into it
here because it be I don't want to do it
via text but yeah there's app he done a
bunch of research and you get a head
start yeah I'll touch Spas with uh
attorne you know what you can do is let
let me know when you're ready to uh if
it's the next meeting or the meeting
after this let me know uh we'll put it
we'll put it on the agenda to keep on
discussing this so
umat thank you Mr chair just just to
throw another curveball at this I know
we're talking specifically charal gaming
but if somebody goes to the extent of
self-exclusion
on uh sports betting for
instance why isn't it why don't we
explore not only the charal gaming
establishments but online Lottery at l i
mean if if you think uh I head to the
point where you and I find it
interesting that DraftKings handles is
but that's another component we could
talk about but if you're excluding
yourself from doing sports betting is
there a component that we can exclude
from online scratch tickets and Power
Ball and and chatable gaming and and on
and on is something we may or may not
want to look at no um the technology
regarding online is very doable uh where
it's the physical it's virtually
impossible to stop somebody from buying
a scratch ticket in a store it' be the
equivalent of stopping somebody from buy
a cup of coffee quite literally there's
1500 locations yeah across the state it
would be it would be not feasible but we
do have a program where we do our sales
if do talk to Clerks and do try and
train the clerks which is difficult
because the average term of employment
for a clerk in a sea store I think it's
like 67 days employment so they
constantly churning employees it's
difficult right so okay these are all
good comments just just refresh my
memory when we did historic racing
didn't we each facility was supposed to
have a
plan to monitor MH so the facilities
also have the ability to say tap
somebody on the shoulder and say Hey you
know we think you're you're exceeding
your as farther application they're
required to submit to uh to us their
responsible gambling plan and then we've
audited that as of I think I mentioned
it before I think four and a half months
ago uh every room was confirmed and
complied with their plane
okay are they identifying problem
gamblers you know what I mean through
that but have to check okay
I'm just curious about that I think
that's part of the larger discussion as
well so there was a plan they have the
plan right but it's it's a plan being
followed you know yeah so okay great all
right well thank you very much um Mora
apprciate you the time
okay so next topic is you know whether
or not we put a cap on the number of
facilities uh or not that's all the I
know this's legislation rolling too at
this point in time about that um but the
one thing that charal gaming never had
an opt-in or an opt out like Lottery it
was an opt opt in right um and and we
did Kino was an opt in like you can't
get pchm opt in right on the Kino so
even though they ERS that or restaurants
that would like to see it so uh so I
know when we were doing historic racing
there was a lot of pressure on me to say
wow why don't why don't we have an opt
in on how ST racing and my response was
well we're talking about the facility
not the specific games that are being
played in the
facility uh that should be regulated so
now
obviously in this discussion I don't
want any facility to get nervous because
we we're not going to
retroactively say your your city has to
opt in if you're already existed you you
you've invested millions of dollars and
you can't you can't reverse it so we're
talking about new communities I think we
should have this conversation uh maybe
uh but I'll leave it at that and Deb uh
Warner um was is is involved in a
specific town and she she has some few
things she want us wants us to kind of
lead our discussion in way about the
situation you've got
okay yeah right there y
yep hello I'm Dr Deborah Warner from
Littleton I am very happy to be invited
to your table to share the experiences
that we've recently gone through uh
regarding the charitable uh gaming and
the historic horse racing um I'll start
with last may we had an organization
come to town that wanted to put in a
casino where the staple store is on The
Meadows our town is 6,000 people but we
are a very um we're a magnet for
Commerce in the North Country I think if
you know about Littleton you know how
very proud We Are of Littleton and how
much we love it um we're listed in the
top 10 places to live in the country so
you feel like candy that's the place to
go that counter it's great we don't have
the world's longest counter they
ever we don't have an empty store on
Main Street we have a good um
development in The Meadows as well um so
last May an organization came through
that wanted to do this where was an a
listening session at the high school
more than a hundred people came in May
which was a lot of people 95 people from
Littleton got up and spoke against
having a casino come to Littleton five
people got up and said they were in
favor of it um it created quite a stir
locally and um quite a few of us got
together and talked about it and saw
well what can we do um there was very
very little seemed that we could do um
but when we did Research into the
statutes and looked at the bills um
House Bill 626 in 2021 and looked at the
reports that were coming out of
committee it did say that we could
control it by ordinance and so we
decided to put forward an ordinance um
proposition well this did not go over
very well at all um the problem with
this was when we got to the planning
board and presented our petition there
was the problem with the Dylan law U
Dylan rule the preemption of the state
over the local Authority and uh so we
couldn't do what we had hoped to do
which was to say not here and so um
we're sort of in a Sticky Wicket with
that at the moment besides that there
was the dread and panic on the board as
they heard our proposition is that just
a few weeks ago Conway had gotten sued
and if you read in the paper I I didn't
talk to them but I did read the accounts
in the paper and the report from the
industrial um consultant said that well
it's not that Conway has denied us or
done something wrong or against us we're
just putting in the lawsuit to hold the
docket open for
ourselves and so that really alarmed the
Littleton planning board and so we're
we're in rather a difficult position as
would be any of the over 200 towns in
our state in that with State preemption
we can't say no and with um
the the industry coming in and doing
preemptive lawsuits it scares the boards
the planning boards quite a bit we are
in a pickle and so you know we're coming
up on the town meeting and all that sort
of thing we're in sb2 town uh so we have
the deliberative session I cannot tell
you what will happen with all of that um
it's it's quite difficult and I think
that the conversations that came out
locally um as we were going through our
recent and current mess with this is
that a local option would be the
cleanest way to handle this if it's at
the state level because then the town
simply has to vote one way or another
and they can't be sued for having a vote
but they SE can be sued easily if they
have an ordinance and you have to defend
it and so um it was generally concluded
that that would be the most wise thing
to do um on behalf of all the towns so
that they could say yes or no and there
are many towns I believe would say yes
but there are towns that might say no as
it seems Littleton might say no we don't
know how the vote would go um but that's
our predicament and I really thank you
for the opportunity to bring it to your
attention because I think it's shared
across the state in any town that might
want to do this and um it's it's not
basically a fair race in the end between
the town and the um guest so let me
there's two two ways of looking at this
first
is uh anord that says no no casinos ever
okay and then there's Z
[Music]
where you say you know casinos can be
only on this part of the town okay so it
sounds like you're you're pursuing to
no we know we know of communities that
have successfully
zoned you wanted to explain Salem uh I
mean they're very very successfully
zoned it's not saying no it's saying
not here in this neighborhood right not
next to the school not next to the
whatever I'm looking at you because I
know Salem has has done that yeah simply
and and thank you for I'm sorry quick
question I'm sorry I'm still horse who
are you representing here who am I
representing are you a band of citizens
a band of citizens okay we have no real
name you said we many times and I was
unaware as to who what we've done in
Salem is exactly that is is Zone
specific
locations that as much as there's a huge
interest and plenty of property and
plenty of space for for uh these
facilities or future facilities to go
that the town fathers the people we put
in place at the local level to control
Our Town took care of it so that that
would be my suggestion it worked great
for for a a bigger town like Salem a
border town that we get a lot of
incoming in relation to terrible gaming
and
yes I I am I understand uh Salem's needs
may be very different than littleton's
you had a rist track there you you have
a different culture um it's part of the
charm of Salem and and yet it's
littleton's not seeing it as
Charming anywhere in town just follow up
yeah follow and I think what you you're
looking for here is an opt-in kind of
option yes and that's something you
should speak directly to somebody
somebody could bring that at any time to
either side of the wall either body here
and it can be examined so something that
can be examined it was said to us by
various attorney type people that that
would be the cleanest option for the
little town to have op op in the only
you go uh the the only curveball is we
don't know if Littleton is one of the
towns
that's um while it sounds like they are
considering it right because the
proposal has been brought forth now
whether or not that would be kosher to
say opt in or opt out when they're
already in the pipeline that's another
thing that you know you got to be
careful of um you know we could pass a
law that says opt in or opt out uh but
if there were already in the pipeline
being considered for an application I'm
not sure that that you know they're
already in the pipeline that that would
be applied so that's the only concern I
got but
U thank you so again putting on my other
hat I was a zoning board chair for a
decade so again under I think you and I
traded some emails as well a while back
um there are I'm always it's an
announcement to me to to start Banning
individual type of businesses from
community
at the state level and say unless they
choose to opt in Imagine a community
that decides it wants to be
environmentally conscious and bans all
gas stations right and and and and that
kind of thing right so it can lead to a
really bad path I think the zoning laws
were were designed such under RSA uh
6748 that allows you to take into
consideration things like congestion of
streets safety from fires and panic and
dangers promote health and general
welfare adequate air and light uh
overcrowding of land undo concentration
of
population um facilitate adequate
provision of Transportation solid waste
all these other kind of things proper
use of Natural Resources there are lots
of things that towns can use to to Zone
to where you want but I I I tend to be
really you know the idea that we're
going to start earmarking certain types
of businesses for exclusion in
communities unless they agree to it um
as a state policy for all towns adopt is
is a little rough for me to swallow
anyway um for that reason um but I do
think you have a plethora of zoning
things you could do that are legitimate
and in statute to earmark where you want
to be able to put these kind of
facilities and and distances from
schools and churches and we do that with
state liquor stores we do it with with
um with vape stores we do it with
cannabis um dispensary stores to say
that you can set a distance from certain
C types of activities like schools where
these can go and and you have supporting
structure within statute I'm not a big
believer I had to add that to my sports
betting Bill back in 2019 when I passed
that law I hated it when I added it but
it was the only way I was going to get
the bill through was to add a local
provision to it and so I accepted it and
swallowed it so that I could make so
that the bill would pass and allow for
um people to be able to if they choose
to bet on sports games here in New
Hampshire um but I I would highly
suggest you look at your zoning or the
zoning law in New Hampshire under under
um 674 17 and see all the conditions and
terms you can put around regulating that
and using that rather than Banning an
individual uh type of um activity
although Al may I go yeah respond please
yes um well this this industry has
already been segmented there's an entire
Commission on it and there is um it's
it's not just like like diesel engine
repair or something like that I I think
you know the commission knows that it's
controversial it's a very specialized
industry it is an industry that's highly
associated with addiction and that those
are the features that do make it
controversial uh in terms of the local
level and so although you were not happy
with the The Kino um op in um we're
delighted with with that option because
it does help the local authorities have
some authority over this
in a measure that they can actually take
so thank you thank you for having done
that even if you didn't like doing it
thank you well I did the same thing with
Kino so um and actually Lottery was opin
for communities and Charlie just left
but I remember his famous story is that
Lottery's you know decades old now right
but um some of the smaller towns didn't
even have a convenience store or
anything so fast for 10 years the town
gets a convenience store they they apply
for uh uh to be able to do get they
wanted lottery in their store you know
trash tickets or whatever and then all
of a sudden they discovered wait a
minute the vote the town didn't take a
vote because everybody forgot Lottery
forgot everybody forgot that that was an
op in um but I think it seems like all
of gambling whatever I think the only
the only exception is is historic uh is
Char gaming that that there isn't some
kind of an op in
provision uh so we understand what
you're saying okay the question becomes
is it you know is it and it was never
one again never one for charal gaming
just it just evolved charal Gaming's
just evolved over the years and and I
was on w means for for 10 year 12 years
and we never we never really talked
about this other than when historic
racing came and I said well you know
yeah we need to we need to address it in
relation to chable gaming not just a s
racing so uh but I think it is something
that as a as a commission we should we
should continue to discuss
um but again OD are the legislature may
take it up sooner that you're urging I
just don't know if you're if Littleton
would be grandfathered in or not I'm
saying um and I I'm not a lawyer so I
don't know
um if I look at you Charlie I mean if if
someone's in the
pipeline and we create a new law you
know we we look retroactively to to us
are they
still uh you know part of the Old Law
not the new law is that something we
should maybe I should look at the a offo
yeah I mean we're the executive branch I
just sort of execute laws pass well
that's another one put on
so it would be an issue if they passed
the zoning ordinance and there was an
application pending because this is an
area of charitable gambling that enjoys
uh field preemption that means that the
state has essentially decided to
regulate in this field and has left to
the towns just their local Planning and
Zoning kinds of things and that deals
mainly with snow removal trash lighting
parking those kinds of things whereas
the state has made a determination that
uh through the legislature that it's
going to uh regulate the field of
charitable gaming uh so uh similar to uh
some moratoriums that have happened in
the past in the waste industry it
wouldn't per se be um an issue if the
legislature decided to make a statutory
change and that was pending be an issue
though if uh they were in the Planning
and Zoning Pipeline and they passed an
ordinance they would be um they'd be
exempt now if they get a license that's
a different situation but if they're
just in the process um there are plenty
of uh examples in New Hampshire law
where things were ongoing and the
legislature may have passed a moratorium
for instance and that put everything on
hold for a time okay some of those
moratoriums never were lifted either
thank you for
that Senator thank you Mr CH M Mr chman
I think the
conversation really sent us around
eration and proliferation has become a
significant issue here where where in
the past there there weren't any rules
or regulations really that governed this
entity it sprang up and all of a sudden
proliferation became the issue and the
number of licenses granted by The
Lottery Commission I mean there was no
restriction uh you took a you took a an
application made a decision on the
application there wasn't any statutory
uh language that said you you couldn't
do that now I acate this to the old
Bingo when Bingo was in every Church
Hall in New Hampshire and the priest
would get up Catholic church and would
say on Tuesday night team number two
will conduct the games and they'll be
downstairs in the church and we'll have
we'll have Bingo and that Bingo was was
uh was given another entity and that was
a little scratch ticket called The Lucky
Seven called the pull tab and they were
25 cents and all of a sudden we started
to Reg in 1973 we regulated pull tabs we
said it would cost $15 a deal there's a
tax on it so forth so that's the first
regulation that I know of that that
appeared having having to do with with
aing but I I think the scope of this
committee is it will be
proliferation it'll
be I guess in direct U direct answer to
your rules is pro proliferation a key
issue it is the local community given
the statutory responsibility that it has
because we always talk about home rule
by virtue of the of the rules that you
have and I'm thinking of a planning
board which re which is really the
entity that would they deal with this
has the has the control has the power
and the AG could address this to say no
that we do it we did it with Kino they
have the ability to say no to Kino so
the question is do they have do they
have the ability to that would be a
legislative yeah sure so if the
legislature wanted to give the
communities theth authority to say no
that's something that would have to be
done through a statute it's it's not
something that the current Planning and
Zoning statutory scheme
addresses but currently and I don't want
to go over with this because I don't
other things but currently look like our
it doesn't look right away it doesn't
look like our three guests
of they will not okay so we have plenty
of time but but currently there is a
planning board situation that's that's
in
effect uh and it's it's it's a situation
where there was a granting a resending a
granting so that thing is it in court as
we speak or by virtue of the of the kind
of activity that's taking place a local
decision was made then a local decision
was changed but that
locality perceives that they have the
right to say
no WR I'm not familiar with the with the
case senator that that you're referring
to so um the the facts yeah the Conway
case cway the cway case oh Conway case I
I'm not familiar with the specifics of
that case I'm sorry okay it's it's the
only one that at the present time that I
know but anyway that I think that sort
of addresses your your your comments but
but in essence doesn't because of
because of the fact that proliferation
has become so strong
and the
Charities have become a a very strong
voice in this and and I think indeed
those are the considerations that we're
going to have to deal
with absolutely so thank you just just
the perception is we had perceived we
had an option to say no we were it turns
out we were not correct when it came
down to the legal analysis that uh
confronted us that the en roll and such
made we can't so we do have it on the
docket for the town meeting I've been
told that if it passes out of you know
if people vote their conscience rather
than knowing that this could put the
town in a pickle um then the town would
not be able to enforce the this
ordinance so we we are going to be one
of the major issues that we're going to
be discussing is the expansion
and are we going to recommend to put a
cap on that whether it be the number of
facilities or to be the number of
historic racing machines whatever form
that that looks like now remember I know
Senator you know this very well and
representative Ames knows this well too
working hard in those days when we're
trying to get casinos not chable casinos
casinos in the state and I think if I
recall every one of those bills bills CU
they always come the way mean Ways and
Means all the time uh had a had an
opt-in
provision a local option and and one of
every one of those so I'm not I'm
personally not I don't object to a local
option uh it's just it's going to be
part of the larger discussion about how
much proliferation is is the word
Senator was using we're going to allow
we're just going to let the market
dictate it uh uh or is now the time
because we're pausing here on everything
having to do with Char gaming it's now
the time and we're not going to go
retrospectively to people the facilities
that exist they exist we're not going to
say those towns have to
vote you know nille or whatever if if
they existing now they can vote possibly
for anything new in that town uh but I
think we those grandfather in you can't
you can't say to a a business that
that's been uh spent a lot of money and
invested that we're going to we're going
to reverse that so that I think that
goes without saying but I think we
should say it though just in case but so
I I think there's a lot of a lot of
history here starting with lottery Kino
sports betting even all of our Casino
bills all talked about a provision an op
in
provision um and that it's probably not
a bad thing to look at as we progress
here as a commission to uh to put as
part of this for packet I don't know if
it helps you in
Littleton uh our timings everything if
we had a commission last year maybe we
would have but um you know but we we
thank you for for coming in and helping
us giving us a real life
example you know and the only other
thing I'll say you know there's other
things like my town doesn't have a
tattoo parlor and I don't think we're
ever going to have a tattoo parlor right
um and I
so I know I never really checked this
let me ask you maybe you know now do we
somewhere along line say the tattoo
parlers are noted in I don't know or you
know but I just don't EnV Vision My Town
ever was saying let's have a tatto par
uh but tat PA are are I mean there's a
little have a top tattoo
paror you know I think it's possible to
get a tattoo in Littleton I believe so
yeah yeah so but those are those are
those are the kind of things that uh
people either would be really for or
really against so so anyway yes any
other
questions oh thank you very much I I do
so much appreciate being invited here to
share this with you and yeah if you do
something about this in in your reports
and your recommendations if the
legislature happens to extend the
moratorium it might very well be helpful
to Littleton over the period of time
yeah again I just told know how that
works if if there's a few uh in the
pipeline right well I don't know what
the pipeline is but you know to the
approval process can they be boxed out I
don't know but anyway well we we do
appreciate it all right thank you thank
you for coming in we love guest I was
worried most about you coming from North
but you had list the North had uh less
know than down here
actually well it was a beautiful drive I
guess getting out of your driveway was
the hardest part right the ski are is a
happy we got good snow okay well thank
you thank you
much okay I actually skipped over one um
when we were talking about the uh
charal uh responsible
gaming last meeting we we discovered Le
uh the commission discovered that one of
the major vendors that's
participating doesn't have breakage in
its in its system
so basically only two of the three
vendors three four or three or four
vendors uh or three of the of the four
vendors or whatever it is one of them
doesn't uh have the ability in their
software to do breakage so to me that's
an issue so how can we have one not
doing it and three doing it so again
well we
we know that breakage has become an
issue and uh CH I think you said that
there was a situation where people
weren't even going to consider it they
weren't going to consider breakage right
you're going to create something that's
going to but breakage has always been
has always been an issue because people
first of all don't understand what
breakage is that's the first point that
should be brought forward and they don't
realize the magnitude of of
breakage uh
because of that intricate situ the
paramutual situation it could be 9 cents
right and and if it's 9 cents and you
got lots of money waged and lots of
races that accounts to a lot of money
and we were told that the breakage this
year from the historic conation Maes
exceeded the
150,000 that we thought it would be
right wasn't that your comment Char was
100,000 exceeded okay 100,000 so so you
got 100,000
here that in the old days was split it
was split between the track and and the
state well now you got a situation where
there's no track you're not going to
give it back to church towns right
because we're just buying the signal at
at this point in time so they're not
entitled to the breakage so who gets the
breakage and how do you how do you how
do you account for the for the breakage
now as I say it was larger than
anticipated with the initial
introduction of the machines well the
machines are are going pretty strong so
the breakage is going to become a bigger
issue now certainly one way to address
it is to eliminate it period and and
just the state would keep it right well
there's a couple options that's why I
want to have to start this conversation
here today and I'm not going to conclude
anything today but so so we have one
that can't doesn't have it in their
software we're not going to tell them
put it in your software right you know
um so now my understanding is that let's
just talk broader let's talk slot
machines too okay right that that these
vendors do pay a fee that's larger than
the fee that we charge them to be to
work
here um I mean is that one option to say
we get rid of the breakage and we put an
annual fee that's more
reasonable on these on these uh vendors
that that's that's one of them now I I
don't want to Blindside them we could
phase that
in uh but I mean that the obviously the
vendors aren't gaining from the breakage
it's just passing through right and they
have the software which they've already
developed so I I just again I'm trying
to get this conversation started here
I'm looking right at you because you
you're from one of the facilities I mean
what's trying to understand what's a
reasonable way of fixing this
um now you could say it's not broken but
I I you know no I I fully understand I I
think one reasonable way to do it would
be go to the one manufacturer who
doesn't have breakage and say um in
terms of your machine placement or games
on your system as a percentage you have
to make up for that or you can fix it
give them the
option either fix it or or make it and
choice
yeah if I could certainly so we're
talking about breakage really breakage
takes two forms with us one is the
breakage for the actual horse racing
simal cast Revenue at the one facility
and obviously there's the breakage that
resists in the store for racing machine
so it's there's two pools of breakage
just want to make sure we're talking
about the historic oration machine
breakage and the lack of uh Unity
uniformity amongst the manufacturers and
that the sound cast not the s cast
correct s cast is fine cor so that's
that's why I I hesitate to sort of say
breakage and sort of not even part of
gaming correct it's not Char gaming
correct and we do get the break correct
and the reason the their revenues are
exceeded is because Ian the revenues
from breakage are larger than we
expected because the revenues from
histor horse racing larger than we
expected so this particular
vendor is it what percentage of the
machines any idea I would would say
probably 50 60% I was thinking 60% of
machines in the state yes that don't
have correct and and and within a pretty
close mathematical certainty we could
come to a number which would we expect
breakage to be on the activity
undergoing now I don't have that you
know I haven't done the back of the
envelope math here but I would suggest
we come with a number that's pretty
close to Accurate so I think they would
understand if we say look we we passed a
statute that said there was going to be
breakage that was going to fund our
responsible gambling
fund and you're not complying with the
law the law said you needed to do this
and they're not doing it so we can we
can give it some time to to either get
that application or say we have to come
up with we have to be reasonable a
reasonable dollar amount that is
equivalent to that um to to play here
what I would suggest I'm sorry
repres just reflecting my ignorance
where this manufacturer
and The Operators that use those
machines where does the breakage money
go now where what's happening to that
breakage money whose money is it so the
breakage actually rolls back into the
prize pool into the pool correct and
that's the paramutual system correct so
that there's no breakage it's just the
the the odd sense is then re re so so my
question is why why is that a problem
it's going back to the to the Gamble in
effect correct it's it's part of the pro
yes as not going to the operator no it's
not not going to the operator North the
state and there's no yeah suggestion to
that it's just that that there's a a
required takeout of breakage that's not
occurring currently so once again we can
fix it and make it so that there's no
breakage and it goes back to the player
across all the platforms but once again
that would require reprogramming on the
rest of the
systems but if we did that then we
I guess what I what I want to understand
is our fees we do charge a fee for the
these vendors to play here right to have
their machines in place manufacturers no
Do all states have them yes usually like
I think the materials I had distributed
two meetings ago right I think Main's is
200,000 I don't know what Massachusetts
is but it's I think it's larger and then
they pay $600 a year per machine
to the state as
well so again we we we got some thinking
to do on this one um again it's like
anything else you know we have a lot of
players coming in here now a lot of
vendors I mean vendors but
um but it's it seems like common
practice to to charge the vendors to be
here except we're giving him a
freebie here you are come on in so uh I
think we have to think about it as a
commission how we want to handle this
not today but it's going to come up on
agenda again give some thought to any
other ideas that people may
have
uh would
the maybe maybe we should bring the
vendors in I don't know talk to them I
don't know I'm trying to be fair here I
mean certainly um they were certainly
here when we were they were here when we
were doing historic racing they they
were sitting at these STS um yeah
there's a couple of them were not all of
them not all of them yeah right so
um I again I I you know we we
could we can well we can do one or three
or four things and we just have decide
which which is reasonable we um fair
this can be um and um he it's almost
like a a retroactive tax I I don't like
that either but uh um but I think the
vendors realized they're boy this is a
good state to come to do this because
we're not being charged anything to to
uh to lease our machines
here
um but we can we can come up a
reasonable number as well it's not as
high as 200,000 a year uh and still I
think we would we would come up with a
number that would
be uh we feel would fund we could point
that money to the CH gaming fund the uh
the problem gaming
fund um and U and say to them hey thanks
for helping contribute to our ter game
because so again um it's not an easy one
because we have to backtrack but again
that they're in violation of the law
that we said that we had
breakage that was going to to the to the
problem ging and you your machines
aren't able to do
that John just a just a general question
um is the problem gaming fund only
funded through breakage or there other
sources well it's it's funded through
the Char Charlie's
budget until they until the breakage
hits that budget amount then right right
and then if if it exceeds the budget
amount then it it
continue uh to go into the fund I guess
right it's actually to be truthful it's
an accounting problem because we're
having too much money and so it says
this money has to go to the to problem
gambling fund but we're in excess of
that so it's I don't explain it but in
the accting we're almost carrying over
revenues for prior years to Future years
to fund problem gambling so when it was
100,000 it was much more than breakage
amount was much higher than the budgeted
amount and so our CFO literally has a
carryover amount from prior years and so
it hasn't really transferred and
honestly for us it's really a rounding
error Le well $187 Million last year is
our net revenue so$ 100,000 is you know
I don't say the rounding ER but in terms
of it kind of is but you know we it was
a I believe it's going to be a finding
on our audit that it's not
properly done
essentially no I
I I do I do commissions have been a lot
of commissions and one was on uh
distribution of electricity and water
and
gas and I had the I had the vendors and
I had all the key all the four electric
companies in the room so we need to
solve a
problem and gave them an opportunity to
come up with a
solution so that's why I wouldn't mind
inviting them to say hey we got a
problem maybe at least talk to them and
say hey we got this
issue uh we were trying to fund our our
our uh problem
gaming um we know you contribute a lot
to other states you're not really
contributing much here what be a problem
if we were to assess a certain amount
and we'd be reasonable and have them
help us carve that out to
be it always works I always start with
is there a problem yes there is okay
let's come up with a solution and we can
have them help us with a solution um um
in terms of what we all think is
reasonable okay well I I think the that
the solution really contains a number of
issues as long as you you have an
expansive situation the breakage problem
will continue to exacerbate because
you're going to make more money so
that's a key issue is there going to be
a situation where some kind of a
moratorium is put on a the number of
machines that are in play in be the
number of licenses that that that you
give if if that problem is is addressed
then the breakage problem is easily
addressed because you make a decision
you say either the software associated
with the machines is is going to be put
in place and there'll be a fee
associated with what breakage used to be
because we can't do anything to the
track they're going to get their brakets
because they they're taking the money at
that end
so the the key element is is going to be
the expansive nature of this
business and is there is there a desire
to cap that now we have two Bills
currently before the legislature that
call for moratorium one is a moratorium
forever and I think another one is is is
sing is it seven
years the piece of so you got two bills
trying to address this this particular
situation it in in my opinion unless we
address those situations and we have to
do that
legislatively uh then the problems that
that we're discussing will continue to
to exacerbate because you got to solve
the big problem first how many how many
in in both instances right and
currently it it's still difficult for me
to get a handle of how many we have in
operation but is it 10 or is it 15 or is
it 10 and five licenses are hanging out
there to be worked worked upon it at
this time before you go Tim um so the
last agenda item is to talk talk about
real quickly the bills that are hanging
out there right now both from the I I I
asked representive to to do because I
think I don't know if you were going to
make it here uh both the Senate and the
house represent said to talk briefly
about the bills that are out there so we
might be able to do that right now and
then we come back to the other gend item
so do we want to try to do that
now okay okay but indeed the the big
problem the big problem we have that's
that's hanging o over us now is how many
in both instances how many licenses are
going to be issued is there going to be
a all right and B is there going to be a
moratorium on on the licenses and the
number of machines that that are given
out that are allowed to be those are the
big questions for the commission looks
like we've got action and both the house
and the Senate um again
it's not a constitutional change so
anything that that happens in the house
at the senate or both agree can be
changed next year after the commission
does their work finishes their work but
um so but
Senator no again so I want to bring the
conversation back to
breakage than a bigger conversation
about perfect liation or HHR in general
so I guess my question Charlie is you
said there's at least one operator
that's not doing break AG right now at
all what manuf call manufacturers is it
they're not going to ever do it or they
have to adjust their software to do it
they would have to up their software to
do it and every machine on the floor
they have
to but have they indicated they will or
won't indicator they will I haven't
pushed the question as
to I can push in order to compel them
but that'll shut down a jar for a period
of time so followup question again I
want to remind everybody I think the
issue is we have too much money um was
the problem was we were we from the
breakage we were already receiving from
the vendors that are doing it was
greater than the expenditure we were
making in in uh breakage and and for the
purposes of responsible gaming and so
there was an adjustment uh to be made in
the budget to to deal with this influx
of Revenue that we had that we had no
place to put because we didn't have an
allocation for it so again the problem
we're resolving is the fact that we get
too much money um in breakage right now
to deal with responsible gaming and I
think we just talked about some some
fixes to that things like the the
Banning and the and the Statewide uh
self-exclusion list and ways we can
spend some of that money to help benefit
the citizens of New Hampshire um and and
deal with responsible gaming on a more
Statewide process rather than Facility
by facility issue which is what we have
now so I just want to again other than
this one vendor which I think Charlie
might have to address but everybody else
is playing by the rules and playing by
by we have and it's being done exactly
the way we intend it the breakage is
going for responsible gaming and it's
and the value is so high that the the
amount that's coming in is higher than
what we were budgeted for and we
correcting that as well so I just want
to Circle it back when we're talking
about breakage and responsible gaming
how that is all that you're playing
together right now I mean I'm happy to
just tell the vendor to pull the
machines and re reprogram it then those
kind off my back just know the the
repercussions down the line but that's
the only and right I don't want to
disrupt anything though so uh that's why
we got to we got to come to terms again
it's not pressing it is
impressing we have until November 1st as
a commission I think we have to address
it in one way or another uh but I think
we need to start the dialogue with this
Fender to say you know help us out here
uh we have a we have a statute in place
that says you know your machines are
supposed to be throwing off some um you
know break
yeah I don't think the statute has any
requirement that there be breakage it
says if there is
breakage then this is what should be
done with it so um it's it's open season
shall we say shall we have breakage or
not the the The Gambler is putting in
$100 and um May it back a lot of money
or a little money and out of the money
that all the gamblers put in there's a
satis side we call it a commission I
think it's been a while since I've
looked at this stuff but uh in any event
uh that's where the money go comes from
that then goes to the operators and The
Operators pay the manufacturers and so
forth and uh the state gets some um and
the rest of the money is in the pool
it's parametrial and uh that includes uh
I suppose it includes breakage I'm a
little confused about the whole breakage
calculations but uh break it that
includes break in a sense but maybe
maybe that that's gone because they're
not they're not handing out pennies
anymore they're they're they're using
computers and they're they're they've
got uh decimal points down to the you
know way way out there and uh so um is
the the G amblers are getting back more
there one way to put it is it's right at
the margin but uh I don't I I don't
understand
why well why we would be able to require
a
manufacturer to produce breakage where
there's no statutory requirement to
start
with well do any statutary thing is that
we said we're going to use breakage and
that so we're going to have two
different systems in place here those
that have machines that have breakage
and those that don't have
breakage so again I don't think it's
that they don't have breakage is what
they're doing with it right they're
rolling it back in versus giving it to
the state for the purpose of problem
gaming and I think this can be an or
addition to legislature right just an or
right so we want the operators to pay a
certain portion to responsible gaming
right that that's not the operators but
the manufacturers right that's the whole
purpose of breakage is it's breaking the
game and we're doing it so it could be
or addition to the language it say
breakage or manufacturer sh right so
they can either submit breakage to the
uh to the state to pay for responsible
gaming or the manufacturer can submit a
fixed fee to the state for problem
gaming and that may resolve the issue
for us and not for Char to take
something
offline I mean certainly like I said
before I I think you can get to a
reasonable number in terms of what that
would
be yeah I think it just
right no no no no no the sast talking
about no that's separate that's no
no so there only one place with sast all
right enough of this for today on this
one um um think about think about it um
we'll bring it up again another
meeting
um I guess uh posted well number six is
postponed U Charlie you still working on
that survey uh yeah certainly um
received back a proposal from
UNH um
and UNH is going to do this the
survey as many charity emails this week
can get I think the proposal had for 575
Charities they would ask 15 questions um
Andy Smith who I think all of you know
of um is going to do the survey his
group out of un and um we should have
results okay going to sort of Look to
Him obviously to You'll all see the
questions that are presented but
certainly Look to Him to draft the
questions to make sure they are
objective and professional research
questions not sort of otherwise right
sometimes the way you frame the question
you get it makes a huge difference
obviously and this you know he's a
professional he's been doing this for a
long time so um look to him to start the
process and so it's a manual process I'm
looking at Val again apologize um
because we have to do the emails by hand
not by hand but certainly it's there's
no database where they can all be loaded
it's like have do it one one at a time
but it's I think it was 575 I think was
the number which obviously n if n equals
575 in a survey that's a stat
statistically valid
survey okay yep was there a timeline for
that
there was it's this spring so I want to
say the next couple months and obviously
that depends on our efforts with him
getting the list and uh the questions so
okay and was Andy Smith yes yeah he's
the director of research for
UNH it was a very reasonable fee so we
just included as part of the lottery
market research budget I think it was a
couple thousand dollars it wasn't
much okay so more on that in future
meeting
um Revenue
growth
um I guess we've been successful here if
I could say in terms of the dollars
Charlie uh office produced this document
which has a lot of good data in it uh by
location uh and I'm not going to go over
this one specifically unless someone
wants to talk about something specific
on this sheet that I that was handed out
is something I
produced uh and the the third the last
two columns were based on the data from
from here so what I did was I I showed
this last meeting and I said we we still
don't have this past calendar year now
we have the the data from of the
calendar year that ended uh in
December and we were looking at was like
a rolling kind of an average if you will
or we looked at last calendar year we
looked at the fiscal year 12 months so
we looked at 12 months of last calendar
year we looked at 12 months again 12
months of the fiscal year that ended in
uh uh June end of June and then we
looked at this calendar year so I had
three data points that are all looking
at 12 months worth of data okay so if we
look at the big numbers on the
bottom uh or the total so we were last
calendar year
total revenues that went to the
facilities charities in the state was
about 74
Million last fiscal year that ended in
June June 30th it was like 117
million and this calendar year it's that
just ended in December about 170 million
so if you look at the bottom you know
year to year those revenues went between
the first two went up 43 million or
59.2% but then then between the the
fiscal year and the calendar year uh
went up another $52 million or another
44.9% but in the 12 months just
comparing last calendar year to this
calendar year that just
ended uh we're looking at an increase of
$96
million
total about
13.6% growth in
revenues and these were after payouts
after everything
so uh and that's obviously been driven
by a lot by the historic racing machines
so we're not surprised that the numbers
gone up but what's a little surprising
is is when you start looking at the
allocation now facility Charities and
state everybody's gone up
uh I mean the big Winners have been the
facilities in the
State uh but the Charities if you look
at
percentages uh you know facility started
at they got 60.5% of
revenues
60.5% in the middle 12 months it was
65.5 and now it's
67.7 Charities were at
27.9% of the take now they're 21 then
then it was
21.2% and now they're down to
18.3% and the state went up from 11.6%
13.3% down to
14% so and what's driving that well we
have
different metrics for allocation for the
table games than we do for the historic
racing machines so as historic racing
machines have grown less of the money
from historic racing goes to the
charities more goes to the state and
more goes to the of G goes the game uh
operators or the facilities I like to
call them so the question on the table
is and this is a bigger question that
that's part of the reason we're bringing
the consultants in uh one of the big
questions I want to see answered is is
especially especially for the historic
racing
machines it are the percent allocations
reasonable or not uh right now and I
know the these things cost me money and
all that but then you could say well a
roulette wheel takes two or three
people uh when it's running uh there's a
certain cost there as well to table
games um labor costs versus machine
costs um and I think to me this is one
of the big things we're going to be
looking at do we need to fine-tune I
mean
do we need to fine-tune those allocation
formulas uh to uh I mean you know when
you just look at in whole numbers the
the Charities haven't really
benefited from from historic racing
machines as much as they should from my
perspective they used to get 27.9% of
the revenues total now they're getting
18.3% of
revenues um and I don't know I need
someone to explain to me
is is that okay or not okay and again
that's what we're bringing in the uh the
lobby the lobbyist the the um
Consultants to show us comparisons to
other states what's
reasonable my
friend thank you and that was my point
these are the raw numbers yeah and we've
both heard testimony relative to the
costs associated in running those HHR
machines in totality so I'd like to see
maybe the operators get involved or
something and give us a line item uh
listing as
to you know this amount came in this is
what the costs were associated this cost
this cost this cost because we took a
lot of that information you you were
still on the committee at the time and
we came to what the breakdown is now
right on its face the way this looks now
I couldn't agree with you more it looks
like something's something's a miss here
but I think we'd need all the
information before we start shooting
uh shoot shooting down that the the
Charities AR getting that you know much
benefit from
this um I mean just to Echo not Echo
that point but certainly to add to it
um we're still early in the revenue life
cycle uh and there are a number of facil
fa ities haven't come online yet and
so we're going to see cannibalization
sooner rather than later and so I want
to know what that looks like before I
come up with it also you be you'll be
able to know if you go with expenses and
revenue now there's no question that's
an easy conversation it's an Excel
spreadsheet but I don't know what that
looks like in a year from now uh in
terms of when more facilities come
online and they get larger or they move
to their soon to be new home etc etc uh
that's a different conversation station
so um you obviously it's a moving Target
OB but um I think it's early but they
can but they can look at things like one
second friend they can look at things
consultant can look at things like how
much each well I know you do this too
you know for this state how much each
machine is
producing to pending right okay so is
this in the ballpark of what other
states are doing with their I mean I
know historic racing machines are in
theory more costly than blot machines
right because you have to pay the fee to
the tracks that are producing the
historic races as well as I guess other
things so but I I I think as a
commission this is this is our biggest
thing that we got to look at um because
the Public's going to ask us i' I've had
people call me we had we had X reps
around my case about you know we gave it
away we gave it away you know so I think
this is the time that we have to pause
and look at this and say is there a
reasonable tweak here that needs to
happen and if so what how much right and
all I'm saying and I get those calls too
is let's have all the information not
just the raw data and and get it from
multiple sources so nobody's cooking
books or or whatever and let's know what
electricity costs what the machines cost
what's you know licensing fees and on
and on and on so comparing Apples to
Apples right it's what's behind the
numbers it's my whole number my whole
career looking at numbers so so I
understand that uh the lbers can lie you
have to really understand what's going
on and that's again we that's one of the
big reasons we brought the consultant we
were bring in the consultant to do some
of that back
room stuff and their experience at other
states to say y this about right or not
right and I'd like to hear
that so again I am I look at these
numbers I'm using the first the first
column and the third column years or
data for data um and you're seeing that
the operators saw a 50% increase in
Revenue right not in 18 you know they
went from 20 million to 31 million right
I mean not the operators but the
Charities went from 20 million to 31
million a 50% increase in Revenue to
charities in just in one calendar year
um and you see a little bit bigger gain
in the in the operators in that same
calendar year but again I I look at you
know I I've gone to a couple of
facilities that tour for them and the
amount of capital infrastructure costs
that they put in um to to gain that
remember the Charities don't have that
capital expenditure um that they don't
they don't have to put out so when
you're looking at things like the brook
or or or gate gay Casino or the Moose um
the amount of capital expenditure that
goes in behind that that create these
Revenue gains there still an ongoing
cost for the operators um so I don't I
just want to be careful we we don't
demonize The Operators here at the same
point understanding that there's Capital
expenditures that go behind that raise
charity revenues by 50% in one year is
because of their investment Capital
Improvements in their facilities um and
that to expand for HHR in this
particular case uh so I think it's
really cognizant that we think about
that that that there's Capital
expenditures behind this that are
long-term debt in most cases that they
they've put some capital in but they've
also incurred debt that they have to pay
off longterm
um and so I I I you know the businessman
and me promoting my own business hold on
a second here it's not all profit right
they're they're in order to get those
those that 50% gain that the again the
Charities saw no exposure to right they
see Zero exposure they just see a 50%
increase in Revenue because the
operators expended the capital funds to
do what they were doing so I want to be
a little careful here when we talk about
this so we don't demonize anybody say
someone's getting a sweetheart deal here
understanding demonizing anybody we are
saying it's now time to pause and to
look at the numbers but facilities their
growth in Revenue just hard numbers
161% and Charities
61% so uh that's what I see here um and
again it could all be justified it could
all be justified but we're done as a
commission I want us all to say someone
stops me in the street and says is this
a fair allocation and you may get
stopped too we want to say yes this is
what we did to look at it and we are
convinced that this is the correct
allocation that's all and uh and uh you
know we'll work with everybody to make
sure it's fair and all that but this is
the time to pause and to look at
that
else I agree with everything you said
and I I think with reference to c l we
don't want to deep iniz anybody that's a
that's a waste of all our time what we
want to come up with is a r rational way
to to make to make a good thing to
retain a good thing because the
Charities the Charities cannot from my
stpoint now this is what I hear from the
Charities and I see him in I see him in
the local bre breakfast place Franco on
the west side of Manchester all right
where you can still get breakfast for a
couple of bucks and we you know they
they got the little Cod for the free L
for the free one we we stamping they
they're
gamblers uh and they see their their
charity and that's that's what they're
laying would be the positive Natures of
boy the charity needs this the charity
needs that because the old ways of the
second collections out guys let me tell
you the second collection's
out and the 25 c seat fee that's good
too so where are the where's the money
coming from right now this is it this is
it for
Charities so we want to make sure that
everything is on the on it's a square
deal for everybody that that that's all
good I mean that i' I've been I've been
in the business for a long time and
uh I I know what I know the value of a
license I know the value of that and
we've we've certainly
uh have a situation there that I think
we have to deal with as as as this
thing rotates on but but I think we want
to do the best for for everybody that's
what I'm saying had represent Janan
first
u i I just have a question if someone
can answer how historically that those
original percentages for HHR allocation
uh came about because they must have
been based on some sort of
calculation um certainly the percentages
related to how much would be the
operators would get how much other would
get State and Charities was get was
negotiated at Ways and Means the
original Bill had a
12% to to the state and Charities and we
negotiated up to
25% um and we based it on in our fiscal
note was a rate of $150 per machine and
I think 1,500 machines Statewide I think
guess we thought we thought the state
would be the amount of machines the
state could have and then what what they
would make per machine that was what it
was based on um obviously there are more
than that I think they're not quite I
think it's
1950 in the state and they're doing much
more than $150 a machine I think they're
at two something so our estimates were
as often are
conservative so follow up I I agree that
you know with the the statements about
we need the data we can't make a final
decision without data but it sounds like
some of the initial uh premises maybe
may have changed with theity of data and
we'll get more data to
see represent
Senator I just want to say that I think
this is great good
work but it begs a lot lot of questions
that's the idea and that's I I want to
reinforce that point uh we're on track
and we were hiring um an entity that
will help us you know get a detail like
this and uh I really see the true
picture this this uh as I understand it
on the screen sheet
includes um historical horse racing but
also includes the other games of champ
CH so this isn't just a picture of what
happened with historic horse racing it's
a picture of the whole we need obviously
need to look beneath that so thanks for
for down this path if you look at this
document you can you could find these
numbers yeah yeah you can see that yeah
so this document let talk about this
yeah this wasn't created for this this
is done by our regularly so this is not
just this we do this every three month
so it's a very a lot of detail here it's
really good uh senator did just a quick
window out to answer representative
question Bob Odell was chairman of ways
and means of the Senate a number of
years ago he put together or we put
together at the time the original
legislation that that granted the
dollars the dollar amounts and the
percentages and so forth and that was
agreed upon by everybody at at the time
we didn't have historic hor racing at at
the time but we had just about
everything else and and the
charities 35% was the key was the key
issue now how that was ascertained
becomes problematic because he didn't
know about the rent and so forth and so
on but Odell's program was accepted by
both the house and the Senate it passed
and we drove on that for for for a few
years uh and and now subsequently
changes have been made uh percentages
have been adjusted but the basic premise
has always been the 35% for the for the
charity I don't think that's changee has
it
sound I mean it's it's less because you
take rent out so that that there's a and
that varies but yeah it's three but that
that was the basis of of of this that
seems to be about right right and I just
keep going back to it because I happened
to be on the committee at the time but
we worked when we worked on on this
but times have
changed the G the game the game has
changed the time the time that you when
you can perform form the activity has
now become 8:00 in the morning till 3:00
in the next morning right in in those we
originally did this they opened up did
they open up at noon I I you know it was
and it was a very short span of time
where where all of this was was
conducted so there's what I'm saying is
dramatic changes have taken place and
they have to be looked at this is an
indication of the dramatic changes that
have taken place just the numbers used
to be a $4 bet now it's what 5050 we got
the $10 B we got this this and so forth
and so on but I think the this is the
most significant is the time change 8:00
in the morning until day the daylight
hours of the next morning I know we did
that my last term I can't remember but
we left it up to the facility
interesting enough a lot of facilities
didn't go to the maximum because there
was none of traffic to make it worth
their while to stay open that late did
did NASA what did you guys
[Music]
realiz right but do you uh would
weekends be a little later
or that's one
okay because the the bar well you can't
serve after 1 o' I forget now you can't
serve liquor here after 1 o00
huh
oh that changed
too see I'm had a let s for a year
thanks J so okay um great uh everybody
any other comments on
this yeah I I would suggest going
through this offline would be great
because really is some interesting data
but it I know technically all of these
facilities are small compared to uh you
know
Encore uh but there really is a range of
size here you can see in the numbers um
as well so uh the last thing and before
we come out try to come up with another
date is uh I to spend five minutes each
I'll look who wants to go first the
senator or the house but we'll let the
house go first about existing bills that
are up there that this this terms
bills real
quick well specific to HHR and Char
bable gaming yeah yeah um got a bill
that uh basically mirrors the amendment
that went to Senate Bill 112 with the
permanent moratorium uh eliminating the
rent excuse me that's that's in
process uh also
uh in relation to poker in these rooms
uh rake with poker um capping that so
they can do now that the bets are are up
uh and the buyin are up that it caps it
at like 250 for a major uh tournament
20% or
250 that's about it
okay I'll do it wrong um we on
tomorrow tomorrow we have uh we're
hearing five we're having public hearing
on five um gaming bills and um you know
in addition to what Fred just mentioned
um we also have
um I think um Senator delis Sandro
mentioned you you guys have a seven-year
moratorium or and um this HP 1255 is
proposing a two-year moratorium um
that's more of an FYI that that's out
there have the meum conference
committee yeah and um well or or the
retain
Bill maybe when I finish we can get a
status on the retain bill sp12 that we
pass on the house um and um what else do
we have
um I think that's
it I think it's what Fred
mentioned all right was you while you're
looking yeah that's Horgan's bill that I
just mentioned twoyear
moratorium um but we're hearing um
yeah
bills let me okay let me just go through
quickly give the Bild number in the in
the title so we're going to hear HB 1203
which is relative to prohibiting the
charging of rent uh to Charities by
charitable Gaming facilities HP 1255 is
relative to Historic course racing
moratorium that's Horgan's bill it's a
two-year extension from 2024 to
2026 um HB 1389 rela to authorizing
persons who win the state lottery to
remain anonymous right that's that's
sear from
what that separate bill that uh
representative kahill put in for just
rent
specific 123 yeah and um yeah that last
one we mentioned doesn't doesn't affect
us so no no exactly uh let's see HP 1525
relative to Historic horse racing game
operator employee
license I don't know if that will affect
us or not um what sen it right right
other than uh and then HP 1549 relative
to uh buy and amount deductions
collected during the operation of games
of
chance I don't know if that's the one
that that's your bill yeah okay yeah so
right and then yeah so I'm just talking
BR sorry sorry about gaming in general
so everyone has a big picture of what's
going on so um we have a bill from Lou
about license renewals on lottery that
we just as a notice requirement for
lottery to to send out uh notices when
when a license is due to expire which we
uh recommended out of pass as amended um
we have an adud dation bill of lose that
um had to do with should the um finding
entity also be the adjudication entity
um in the purpose for the purpose of of
infractions um we been an inter study on
that because we think that's a bigger
Statewide discussion involving Dees and
weights and measures and you name the
agency who also finds and then decides
to also play judge as well we think
that's a bigger discussion the state
needs to have so we interim studied that
bill um we we have a bill on um uh uh
repealing simoc cast dog racing um we
are recommending otpa we're pushing that
out three years there are only two
entities in the state that currently are
grandfathered in for dog racing we want
to give them time
to wind that down rather than just cut
them up so we gave we uh we back up you
did do we're going to do away with dog
dog simult dog racing dog racing only uh
simal gas dog some people don't like so
um it's a threeyear push out I believe
um is what we did to give there's only
one entity that that currently does it
it's a $900,000 hit to that one entity
um and so we want to give them time to
phase that in and ramp that in and work
with that um those betters May bet on
horse racing what's that they may they
may they may just shift but the problem
is that there are some employees that
work just that industry and know that
industry that help better on that
industry and we want to give them time
to train and do things for those
employees um we have the return of the
advanced deposit wagering which is the
online horse betting Bill coming back uh
we currently allow Off Track Betting in
person but we don't allow off trck
betting remote um it's to clean up that
language because there's some federal
statute that says yes we can some State
Statute that's unclear that bill will be
coming back um we have not exec that
bill yet um we have um um the the return
of the historic horse racing with the
additive licenses with the moratorium
that's a sevene bill I'll be Shifting
the municipal um host language into that
bill um allowing for 10 days uh based on
that bill um we would be adding sorry I
did my math over here somewhere um
another we'd have end up with over
14,000 days of of charitable gaming
available in the state of New Hampshire
with 20 licensed op operators um that
could do two Charities per day one for
gaming operat one for games a chance and
one for um so it turns out to be over
14,000 days we're asking for 200 those
days to go to the towns to um help
offset local Municipal costs and lower
property taxes um so that bill will be
being heard um it's been heard we're
working through amendments um we have a
bill on unclaimed horse uh historic
horse racing voucher tickets um there's
a
a weird Gap in the law where um
unclaimed horse racing tickets don't
have a name associated with it and so
you get a ticket it's for you know you
played your bet all day long and you get
your your voucher at the end it's for $2
and you don't go to the cage and cash it
what happens to that $2 x c um there's
no name right now it goes they would
have to be submitted as individual
receipts to the treasury who would then
hold it for another two three years with
an unclaimed unknown person to go claim
their $2 and whatever cents um it seems
like a huge administrative burden so
what we're going to do is basically
allow the um gaming operators will
submit once once a year a check to the
treasurer to go to the governor's
scholarship fund for all the money and
it'll just be directly deposited because
you can't put it to a name there's no
way for someone to claim that money so
that money will just go to the governor
scholarship fund to support higher
education here in the state of New
Hampshire is that a carrier for when we
have real hor racing
yes it's one of those things yeah but
but but the interesting thing about
horse racing is you can go tie it back
to en count yeah right because you got
to go place a bet and sometimes you can
tie it back if you're doing the the dep
Advanced deposit wager and kind of stuff
you can tie it back the
administrator yeah this is an unknown
claimed entity so anyway that money will
go to the uh go to the governor's
scholarship fund to support um that and
the last one we did what's the last one
no um we have a weird thing about
charity auctions having auctioneers
being able to work for charity auctions
apparently there was a weird rule that
if an Auctioneer came in was auctioning
we' they had to go through a criminal
background check and a whole bunch of
other work just because they were acting
as the auctioneer um and we did away
with that requirement so that they can
go in they can sign a contract with a
charity perform an auction because they
never touch ownership of the property or
the money they can just do provide the
service at no and and go through and
they don't have to do all that
background check um and then lastly
um they Advance deposit wagering bill
again oh that's an amendment that's it
so we havek you thanks for that update
appreciate
it John can we get an update on SP sp12
rou bill so sp12 is just being held in a
bance right now we we're not acting on
it in any way shape or form at the
moment okay um next
meeting obviously we're going to I'll
invite these sh is back yes other
business oh I'm sorry yes I'm sorry uh
as other business um our office would
like the commission to perhaps uh think
a little bit about enforcement as the uh
industry here in New Hampshire grows uh
the way that uh our charitable gaming
laws are currently enforced are a
combination of State local and Lottery
Commission and so one of the things that
what that that we see being an issue is
as this industry grows as the revenues
in this industry become much larger are
there adequate resources in place in
order to enforce our laws uh we would
think that maybe starting with uh some
guest speakers from Massachusetts or
Maine to come in and talk about some of
their enforcement mechanisms uh might be
a way to you know kick that off but you
know we're just looking at this from the
standpoint of you know once this
industry kind of gets moving uh which it
really has but once it starts getting to
the level where uh it's kind of above
what local law enforcement can do at
that point some state law enforcement is
going to probably need to be the folks
that uh are dealing with uh with any
potential gambling crimes and right now
our office isn't really set up for that
um nor do I think is the Lottery
Commission so they don't have have any
criminal investigators in their
organization so we would be relying on
local police to do those kinds of things
that might not be realistic on a go
forward basis so that's some of the
things that you know conversations we've
had internally also on the civil law
side going through the actions of uh you
know either suspending or revoking a
license how that is handled uh who from
the AG's office may be needed to uh you
know go ahead and prosecute those kinds
of things we're right now looking at at
it as a civil function versus a criminal
one I could agree more that that we to
me in the back of my mind I know we were
going to be looking at is there enough
resource to to properly oversee this
from a criminal uh standpoint so that's
something that we'll do and that's
probably a good idea to try to bring in
these other states again to see if they
can help us out with what they're doing
I'm assuming that the consultant was
supposed to to me the consultant was
supposed to also kind of touch on these
things too how we structure do we have
the right resource here and clearly I
mean Charlie you're saving the day with
your all your
revenues in the State uh I mean I do
look at the revenue focus and it's it's
amazing um and some of it has to do with
travel gaming but most of it has to do
with sports betting probably but uh so
with
that uh let's let's talk about the next
meeting certainly we'll have the these
three speak speakers that we're going to
be here today back uh we'll see where we
are with the
RFP I don't know if the time will be
right I'm bar looking at that end of
February like three weeks out
still
um which which's vacation week for the
legislature last week 26 Monday 26 on
that that
week
uh and know I I think last time we were
looking at the 19th through the
20th
um to uh to meet and then I know you
said your meetings your ways and means
meetings are on Mondays or
Tuesdays
U I'm look at the two chairs here then
then then Senate when when the wday
mornings huh Wednesday mornings is
yours
what if on
the what if on the 19th we started
earlier than 10 o'clock 19th President's
Day I'm not sure oh it's President's Day
oh my oh bad
idea thank you for that
one
um well well
4th jeez I didn't want to wait that long
um what about the Tuesday let's just
talk about Tuesday the 20th I I have
sent an education that morning um okay
Tuesdays and Wednesdays in the morning
and both days all right we're taking
up okay we're going to skip a whole
another week with the the vacation week
for the
legislators um which have been to the
4th
Monday I guess the only benefit there is
that we would have had our chance to
select our our
vendor do you think by the 4th
March and then we might want to invite
them here it's not you work it's not
that all
right but if we did something like even
on the how about Friday the
23rd can we meet I hate to change the
day
but who who can't make the
23rd which which February February
23rd does that work for
everybody oh you had something yeah I I
won't be here you won't be here a lot of
people are leaving all right they're
leaving to go right for the
break all
right 22nd I think the house is going to
be in session
and so is the Senate and the 21st the
Senate s session in the afternoon all
right all right let's through March 4th
and uh usual time 10 o'clock and then
I'll going to try to squeeze another
meeting in March as well try
to so March 4th yeah 10 can I check with
your assistant to see if I can steal
this room okay if not we'll we'll see
okay so March 4th 10
10:00 okay any other
discussions nope okay thank you all it
was good meeting appreciate it and all
your input thank
you